this ancient religion tells us the truth
about both zorro and the sun gods nika
it's really no secret that one piece is
largely inspired by mythologies from all
around the world from sengoku's golden
buddha mythical zone to the nordic roots
of elbaf giants oda has clearly studied
his myths and legends extensively
however one piece also shares a lot of
its mythology with an ancient religion
that you might not be as familiar with
zoroastrianism the connection between
these two runs so deep that oda might
have taken inspiration from this
religion for at least two of his major
characters and so today i want to take a
closer look at the zoroastrian roots of
the sun god nika and even ask could
rodonoa zorro be short for rhodanova
zoro wester well before i tell you why
the answer is probably yes make sure you
subscribe for more content like this
every single week as we wait for hirola
to reveal the secrets of the sun god
nika and joyboy now is the perfect time
to theorycraft and see what we can
uncover from the rich secrets that make
up the fabric of the one-piece work
while pulling from so many mythologies
from all around the world oda still
manages to weave a cohesive narrative
which is a really impressive feat being
able to pull together so many different
parts into a solid hole but perhaps as
the user
jammypants915 on my subreddit has found
out there's something about all these
mythologies that helps him along the way
so oda is bringing in elements from
abrahamic religions like christianity
and islam kumar carries a bible and the
quran features a story of the sakum a
tree in hell that grows actual devil
fruits that might be new to you right
and he also incorporates eastern
religions of course like hinduism and
buddhism again we have sengoku's
daibutsu fruit and of course zaro taking
the form of ashura oda even borrows from
beliefs in norse or ancient egyptian
mythology as well we're all looking
forward to meeting prince loki of elbaf
there is shanks and we remember pel and
chaka's fruit which allowed them to take
the shape of animals that resemble the
gods of the egyptian pantheon the jakar
fruit essentially turned chaka into
anubis while the falcon fruit gave pel
the traits of the egyptian gods horus
the jury is still out though on whether
horus could also survive massive
explosions of a giant bomb but anyways
what if these separate influences play
together so nicely because there are
common threats that run through all of
them well it turns out that almost all
of these religions all over the world
were influenced or inspired by
zoroastrianism in case you're wondering
what the heck that is let me give you a
quick rundown of it before we get into
why it's connected to one piece
zoroastrianism is the world's oldest
known monotheistic religion or the first
major religion to teach that there is
only one supreme gods it originates from
persia located in what is now modern-day
iran this faith is based on the
teachings of a super ancient prophet
called zoroaster or as you might have
heard someone called zaratustra and so
some of the defining features of its
belief systems center around the duality
between good and evil and the eternal
battle between the two and these tenets
of zoroastrianism have become so
widespread around the globe that they've
influenced many other faiths throughout
the world including christianity islam
hinduism and many many more
zoroastrianism might also well be the
world's oldest continuously practiced
religions with many people in the world
still adhering to the zoroastrian phase
to this day one famous practitioner that
you might be surprised at was none other
than queen singer freddie mercury for
instance but clearly now that we know
that the galailla company's peopley
lulu's resemblance to freddie mercury
was no mere coincidence and one piece's
connection to zoroastrianism has been
hinted at way way back all along okay
maybe the freddie mercury one is a bit
of a stretch but now that we've covered
the basics of zoroastrianism it's time
to really dig into how it inspired one
piece so much including sun god nika and
zoro zoroastrian teachings say that the
world was once pure and good but was
slowly corrupted by evil forces however
to defeat this evil and return the world
to its ideal state every 1 000 years a
hero is reincarnated or reborn until
finally with the last cycle the hero
finally vanquishes these forces of evil
now this is a very stark simplification
of some very complex theology of course
you can learn more about it if you get
your hands on a copy of the avesta the
sacred text of zoroastrianism but even
that bit of information should scream
one piece to you like everywhere
everywhere one piece is all about
inherited will almost all of the straw
hats and many other characters have
inherited the will of someone close to
them and luffy himself seems to share so
many parallels with the former king of
the pirates goldie roger roger himself
was too early in arriving to love tale
it seems that there is a cosmic calendar
counting down the time towards some
cataclysmic destiny and luffy is the
fated hero to take part in a great
battle that determines the future of the
worst but most recently we're seeing
that luffy appears to be a reincarnation
of swords for joy boy we know very
little about joy boy so far but we do
know that he played a significant role
in the void century which happened
nearly 1 000 years ago somewhat in line
with zoroastrianism cycle of the reborn
hero another important connection to
zoroastrianism comes from zorro himself
i mean zoroastrianism it's possible that
oda got zaro's name from this religion
because most western viewers of course
when thinking of the name zorros think
of the swashbuckling pulp hero zorro
with two r's but despite antonio
bandera's impressive sword-wheeling
skills the rest of the comparison really
falls apart quite quickly in fact we do
know that zoro wasn't actually named
after this other hero and thanks to the
similar name we now have zorro with two
hours to thank for every english reader
having to suffer through the official
translation calling our favorite
swordsman zolo thanks for that i guess
quick bonus fact here if you're
wondering where the roronua part comes
from well that's derived from the real
life pirate francis
i guess i mean you get it
it's the japanese rendering of that
anyways back to zoroastrianism one of
the most important connections to zorro
is his ashura technique today asuras are
known as divine beings within hinduism
and buddhism but their lineage can
actually be tracked all the way back to
zoroastrianism in fact the supreme god
of zoroastrianism is known as ahura
mazda the ahura pronunciation and
spelling shifting to asura as it moved
across different places times and
languages another connection between
zorro and zoroastrianism comes through
his many brushes with death now it's
said that in climatic battle the great
hero of zoroastrian myth will cause the
dead to be reborn and for the souls lost
in the underworld to be purified and
brought back to the lights and so i
really couldn't help but notice that
zoro has been having a really recent
encounter with the grim reaper himself
but until we find out more about what
that situation was all about it's really
hard to speculate if there is a
connection here another connection
between zoroastrianism and one piece has
to do with fire and light luffy has been
shown to have unexplained powers to
conjure fire he's the foretold hero that
will bring the dawn of the world the one
who will shine light again on the world
that has been shrouded in darkness and
it just so happens that fire and light
are crucial symbols in zoroastrianism in
this religion there is a practice to
light an eternal flame within a place of
worship called a fire temple that sounds
pretty cool and so when the ideas and
values from sorrow astronism are passed
from one person down to the next it is
symbolized by a new flame being lit from
the existing one thus an eternal flame
one that endures the flow of time
represents an inherited will not too
dissimilar from the concept of inherited
will within one piece speaking of
inherited will in addition to being a
new joy boy it would seem that luffy is
also related to a figure called the sun
god nika in zoroastrianism fire is used
to represent the gods ashura mazda and
in addition to this there is also a
zoroastrian moral code that follows
three main principles good thoughts or
pendant good words or golf darnique and
good actions or kerdanique the word nik
which can be translated as good true or
chosen just so happens to be where the
persian name nika originates
the name of the sun god nika literally
comes from zoroastrianism so if you
weren't convinced by any other pieces of
evidence so far i'm sure this one will
make you think twice and while we
focused on the zoroastrianism side of
argument hora sensai also dives deep
into norse mythology as well it's of
course the inspiration for both the
giants of elbaf and our red-haired
legend shanks now shanks and luffy are
bound to meet very soon and if you want
to know why this will most likely take
place on elbaf and why luffy must fight
his mentor at some point you really
can't miss out on this video right here